c'est d'abord la stratégie du
rassemblement national pour ces
législatives avec jonathan dutriez
en retrait depuis plusieurs jours marine
le pen se doit de reprendre la main en
vue des législatives
car face à elle jean luc mélenchon dans
sa posture de rassembleur de la gauche
entend lui ravir le titre de premier
opposant à emmanuel macron à l'issue des
législatives
hors de question pour elle alors marine
le pen frappe fort le chef de file des
insoumis devait bien qu'un certain
nombre de personnes cherchent à exister
parce qu'ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas
atteint le second tour mais la réalité
c'est que compte tenu de la tri
polarisation de la vie politique jean
luc mélenchon ne sera jamais premier
ministre en revanche si hassen terme de
français votent pour lui il peut
transformer l'international en zad de
son côté jordan bardella à préciser la
stratégie du r n en vue du scrutin
569 candidat investi avec l'ambition de
porter en priorité des mesures pour le
pouvoir d'achat quant aux objectifs
politiques le rn espère se doter d'un
groupe de poids à l'assemblée nationale
pour faire barrage à emmanuel macron une
projection opinionway donnent le parti
entre 20 et 40 députés jordan bardella
préfère rester prudent comprendrez qu'il
m'est impossible de vous livrer un
objectif chiffré du nombre d'élus
espérer dans le mode de scrutin rend son
issue imprévisible notre objectif est
simple en faire élire un maximum et se
doter du groupe le plus puissant demain
au parlement
tardivement mais sûrement le rn est bel
et bien lancée dans la bataille des
législatives
marine le pen et jordan bardella
s'élanceront dans un tour de france en
soutien au candidat investi par le rnd
le débat a déjà commencé sur ce plateau
ça discute pendant le reportage pierre
chartier bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste et essayiste catherine
tricot bonsoir mais mieux vaut aussi
directrice de la rédaction de la revue
regards j'accueille allemand bruno
cautrès politologue chercheur au cnrs et
au cevipof bonsoir à tous et bienvenue
et matthieu croissandeau élite rice
politique autour
mathieu bienvenue à vous aussi j'ai
envie de dire il était temps pour marine
le pen quatrième tricot est ce que vous
diriez que je sais pas c'est moi c'est à
peu près sur ses listes latine
m'intéresse pas vraiment
je sais pas si ça les intéresse pas
vraiment elle était un peu parti se
reposer probablement mais ce qui est
assez étonnant c'est qu'elle ne parle
pas elle n'est pas très présente et
montant elle progresse un tout petit peu
dans les sondages du jour déjà le cas
mais c'était déjà le cas l'an t
présidentielle on se rappelle que
pendant que eric zemmour occupé des
plateaux faisait du bruit et du
tintamarre ll était quand même à bas
bruit et finalement elle réussissait à
infuser ses idées ce localement donc
finalement avoir une certaine discrétion
ça ne nuit pas forcément un marine le
pen ce qui est étonnant plus tôt c'est
le thème sur lequel elle finalement et
commencent à rentrer en campagne où elle
fait c'est vraiment mélenchon son ennemi
est le hamas qui est étonnant là on a
entendu un extrait de son intervention
sur rtl ce matin mais les explications
sur la zad que je vais vous proposer
dans dans un instant et je voudrais
d'abord vous donner la parole aux uns et
aux autres clercs chartier qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait penser de sa stratégie
notamment ce refus de pactiser avec avec
reconquête avec eric zemmour bah je
pense que précisément par rapport à jean
luc mélenchon dont elle a fait elle
aussi l'homme à abattre un passant qui
est malade mâcon à mon avis elle a
vraiment un argument politique puissant
a tiré de l'alliance qui vient d'être
constitué à gauche parce qu'elle peut
apparaître elle est d'ailleurs elle en a
joué parce que c'est ce qu'elle a évoqué
ce matin à la radio elle peut apparaître
comme celle qui elle ne trahit pas ses
électeurs ne pactise pas avec des forces
qui serait vaguement enfin de la même
famille mais qui ne serait pas conforme
à tous les engagements qu'elle a tenu
elle la zone d'électoral quoi est
exactement elle a évoqué
eric zemmour notamment sur la question
de la retraite retraite à 65 ans qui
était promue par les risées mois et qui
n'est évidemment pas l échine le repas
par un parmi ces propositions donc elle
peut apparaître comme celle qui incarne
une forme de pureté de sincérité
d'authenticité est simple c'est assez
malin parce qu'effectivement c'est une
qualité qui apparaît comme une qualité
majeure chez les français lorsqu'on les
sondes sur les dirigeants politiques et
les qualités idéales qui pourrait leur
traité donc je trouve que c'est assez
c'est assez malin comme du pain c'est
pas elle qui l'a elle profite de la
situation mais mélenchon au fait lui
offre cet argument politique bruno
cautrès les coléus ce contrat ça ça vous
aussi d'ailleurs pour la majorité
présidentielle avec un jean luc
mélenchon qui a occupé occupé occupé
l'espace en a quasiment fait tous nos
débats sur cette nouvelle union
populaire économique et social la
semaine dernière et marine le pen est
parti en vacances est ce que c'est une
erreur stratégique un peu oui c'est un
peu une erreur stratégique parce que en
matière de dynamique d'une campagne
électorale
celui qui arrive à préempter le terrain
de la bataille voir définir le terrain
de la bataille s'en sort toujours mieux
généralement ça ils arrivent à planter
le décor il a posé la question il arrive
à faire poser une question à ces
élections législatives qui partait pour
être des élections de confirmation on
disait l'abstention va chuter c'est le
3ème et le 4ème tour de la
présidentielle et lui a repris la main
très vite en disant non il ya un
troisième tour qui est politique donc il
arrive est un tour de force qui est
d'arriver à donner un sens politique à
un cadrage assez nette à cette élection
présidentielle qui ont qu'il a proposé
de faire des élections pas d'élections
législatives qu'il a proposé de faire
vraiment une interprétation politique
n'a une élection de combat alors que sa
part était parti pour être une élection
de confirmation donc de ce point de vue
la marine le pen il était très urgent
qu'elle essaie de reprendre de reprendre
la main parce que c'est vrai que
maintenant que le coup est parti du côté
de jean luc mélenchon ça va être très
difficile pour marine le pen de recadrer
quelque chose qui soit spécifiquement
rassemblement national revenir sur ses
thèmes de campagne présidentielle elle a
cité ce matin dans l'interview rtl le
pouvoir d'achat non mais moi je
m'attendais à skis emmanuel macron tout
de suite ils viennent sur le pouvoir
d'achat mais quelle un coup est parti à
gauche il va falloir un peu ramé pour
marine le pen pour venir à nouveau sur
ces thèmes le pouvoir d'achat par contre
partager l'excellent ce qui vient d'être
dit sur au fond elle se situe elle dans
l'espace de la pureté des convictions
l'absence de compromission elle refuse
toujours toute alliance avec reconquête
et elle parle aussi un peu un électorat
de droite ok alors qu' à qui la droite
s'ils ne parlent pas beaucoup en ce
moment en venant sur un thème qui est
mais attention jean luc mélenchon à
l'assemblée c'est la salade c'est
l'extrême gauche donc là aussi ça elle
essaie d'aller capter un peu d'électeurs
de droite mathieu vachon qu'elle est
dans un entre deux entre deux scrutins
qui est le scrutin du 2 rassemble
nationale et anciennement du front
national la présidentielle et un scrutin
qui n'est pas du tout celui du
rassemblement national qui est g7 il
rappelle que la dernière fois elle a
fait 33 % au second tour elle n'a eu que
huit députés de l'est aujourd'hui ces
sept députés +1 apparentés lorsqu'elle
est dans un entre deux humains ya une
forme de décompensation après une
présidentielle quand vous avez raté
c'est humain ça n'a pas touché jean luc
mélenchon cette fois ci mais celle-là
touché les deux fois précédentes on ce
de façon différente en 2012 ou en 2017
moi ya quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est cette affiche qu'on a vu
dans le sujet pour la campagne des
législatives de marine le pen vous avez
deux visages celui de jordan bardella et
celui de marine le pen c'est la première
fois dans une affiche du lui
historiquement du front national
aujourd'hui de l'assemblée nationale
qu'un autre visage car le pen sur la
fiche et là on à jordan bardella
d'accord vous me dire il est président
par intérim en entier rim qui dure du
rassemblement national mais il n'est pas
candidat aux législatives
donc on a quand même la tête de jordan
bardella qui n'est pas candidat aux
législatives qui veut faire comme aller
jusqu'au bout sont les européens en même
temps que celle marine le pen comme si
il y avait à sage dérogation comme si on
avait prévu deux hypothèses comme si
voilà je trouve que c'est ça interroge
ses interroge sur la suite heures jeudi
pas du tout que marine le pen va prendre
sa retraite dépasse a annoncé qu'elle
est candidate dans sa circonscription du
pas-de-calais à un moment où elle sera
vraisemblablement réélu mais je pense
qu'elle est dans un entre deux sur ses
ambitions et c'est vrai que sa stratégie
et pose question moi je ne partage pas
forcément l'avis sur la pureté parce que
d'un strict point de vue électoral
aurait mieux fait quand même deux et
avec avec eric zemmour ans même s'il ya
eu tous les noms d'oiseaux pour la
campagne parce que ça lui aurait permis
de d'avoir des alliances au premier tour
ce qui leur plus de chances de se
qualifier au second et puis et puis
ensuite je trouve que sa stratégie de
dire maintenant de toute façon j'aurais
jamais de commutation de toute façon et
même à croire à sa majorité c'est pas
très mobilisateur avant avant un premier
tour en gros on a perdu mais allez-y
quand même voter pour moi histoire qu'on
ait le plus de monde possible je trouve
que c'est un entre deux même stratégie
alors vous en parler des alliances
possibles avec reconquête je vous
propose d'écouter
guillaume pelletier qui était sur ses
news et comment vous dire ben il
continue de tendre la main claudia
marine le pen si vous voulez être
crédible et qu on vous croit quand vous
attaquez à jean luc mélenchon emmanuel
macron alors accepté la main tendue
d'eric zemmour parce que seuls des
centaines de députés patriotes et de
droite pourrait s'opposer à la politique
de maquereaux et mélenchon c'est un
petit peu pathétique quand même quatre
nouveaux noms oui surtout c'est que là
je veux dire marine le pen n'est
vraiment pas prêt de faire et danser
avec eux parce que c'est la dessert
enfin je veux dire je pense que c'est
pour ça qu'elle ne le fait pas c'est pas
seulement pour entretenir sa pureté
c'est qu'elle sait très bien que c'est
un repoussoir et que cette
l'extrémisme qui a été développé par
eric zemmour ne contrevient à sa
stratégie à la fois de normalisation et
d'élargissement du spectre aussi faire
quand même marine le pen ce qu'elle a
voulu dire c'est que je ne suis pas
simplement là pour parler de
l'immigration elle a voulu se
positionner sur de nouveaux sujets le
pouvoir d'achat mais on se fait qu'elle
était entrée en campagne sur la question
des libertés vont donc elle cherche à
élargir son assise pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle viendrait se rétrécir sur ces
bases là je pense que ça lui rapporte
rien je pense qu'elle n'a aucune idée
qu'elle puisse être quelques 7 premier
ministre et donc c'est pour ça aussi
qu'elle va pas chercher jean luc
mélenchon y croit-il vraiment peut-être
pas mais en tout cas elle ne peut pas
jouer cette carte là donc
l'idée de faire des alliances pour avoir
des centaines de députés mais ça
d'autant que ce matin elle évoqué les
classes moyennes ça m'a frappée elle a
insisté dans son intervention sur sur
les classes moyennes ont concentré bien
qu'effectivement elle vaut cibler elle
veut élargir son électorat et que les
classes moyennes elles sont pas
forcément sensible au discours d'eric
zemmour donc ça va tout à fait dans le
sens qui vient d'être dit et puis en
plus elle sait aussi que finalement en
comparaison des macros ou de jean-luc
mélenchon elle a pas beaucoup de
territoires où il est arrivé vraiment
ans taylor justement donc du coup ça lui
donne pas énormément de possibilités ça
donc du coup enfin le combat est d'une
certaine manière en partie joué déjà
pourquoi s'efforcerait tel doublé toutes
ses forces dans la bataille alors
seulement la géographie électorale on va
parler tout de suite avec steve jour
d'impôt qui va nous donner des nouvelles
steve de de reconquête on a une raison
que ça patine un peu à la proche de ses
délices latif oui mais ça il faut
surtout pas l'iran n'allait pas le dire
un responsable du parti en apparence
tout va presque bien reconquête c'est un
parti jeune 1 qui compte officiellement
plus de 125 mille que je me trompe à 566
adhérence c'est le décompte officiel
c'est beaucoup hein c'est quasiment un
mouvement de masse à l'échelle française
à titre de comparaison le parti
socialiste officiellement environ à 20
il ment répit regardez cette photo
thomas sotto elle avoue claire c'est
eric zemmour qui réunissait lundi à
paris à la salle wagram les candidats
reconquête au législatif sur le papier
tout va donc très bien eric zemmour qui
hésitent encore à se présenter lui même
il est fier de présenter cinq cent
cinquante candidats aux scrutins au
scrutin du mois prochain écoutez le
regardez-vous parmi nos 550 candidats il
ya des profils si différentes il y à des
étudiants et je salue toute la
génération z qui va aller partout
combattre sous nos couleurs à l'image de
son responsable
nice l'as rigaux il y à des policiers il
y à des fils et des filles d'ouvriers il
y à des enseignants il ya des ingénieurs
des médecins des chefs d'entreprise vous
avez des profils différents et pourtant
vous vous battez pour un même idéal
la france doit bien en apparence mais
derrière la façade il ya quelques
lézardes sont il faut gratter un peu
elle a confirmé hier dans un post publié
sur les réseaux sociaux marion maréchal
ne sera pas candidate aux législatives
raison invoquée ces huit mois de
grossesse marion maréchal écrit qu'à
huit mois de grossesse et bien elle ne
sera pas en mesure de mener une campagne
de terrain elle ne sera donc pas
candidate dans le vaucluse le vaucluse
où eric zemmour était arrivé seulement
4e à la présidentielle autres
responsables du mouvement qu'ils
pourraient ne pas en être c'est
guillaume pelletier vous en parliez tout
à l'heure thomas députés transfuges les
républicains du loir et cher c'est le
seul député sortant reconquête mais il
hésite à y aller il faut dire que dans
sa circonscription eric zemmour est là
encore arrivé 4e guillaume pelletier va
faire connaître ses intentions dans les
heures qui viennent et puis lui non plus
n'ira pas lui c'est samuel la faune le
monsieur le monsieur réseaux sociaux
d'eric zemmour il était annoncé candidat
dans le gard il a finalement jeté
l'épongé raison officielle une
incompatibilité d'agenda le gars est un
département où eric zemmour était
arrivée quatrième voilà quatrièmes au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle il avait fait 9,7 pour
cent des suffrages en attendent
maintenant la décision d'eric zemmour
ira-t-il hérite ira-t-il pas s'il va ce
qu'il ira à paris est ce qu il ira dans
le var en tout cas thomas il n'y aura
vraisemblablement pas de groupe roquette
à l'assemblée nationale au mois de juin
alors pour un candidat lambda pourquoi
se présenter si c'est pour perdre est ce
que c'est simplement l'intention qui
compte finalement que tu es la réponse
du sénateur sébastien meurant c'est pas
l'intention qui compte c'est
l'engagement qui compte et c'est
l'engagement au service d'une cause qui
est noble contrairement à être en marche
on sait pas où on va nous on sait où on
va et les 550 candidats qui vont aller
se présenter ils savent où il veut mener
ils veulent mener la france et ça c'est
un engagement qui sera quoi qu'il arrive
noble et quoi qu'il arrive est utile
pour le pays et pour eux donc ce sera la
vraie ne pas de défaite
honorât que les victoires que des
victoires au rang des victoires ces
dernières heures du côté de reconquête
la candidature de stanislas rigaud le
porte parole du parti il est jeune il a
23 ans il a refusé les avances du
rassemblement national il se présentera
sous les couleurs de reconquête dans le
vaucluse merci steve pour toutes ces
informations claires chartier quand on
fait le bilan de cette campagne 2022
d'eric zemmour qu'est-ce qu'il va rester
quand même une énorme
déception du côté de guérison enfin
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui était
personnelle il disait j'ai pensé en
regardant votre reportage disait que au
lendemain des élections il allait être
s'il ne devenait pas enfin s'il ne s'est
pas qualifié il serait toute façon le
chef de l'opposition
quand même avoir ce type de propos dans
la position dans laquelle il était je
crois surtout que effectivement c'est
quand même ya quelque chose d'assez
romanesque dans cette trajectoire parce
que c'est un personnage qui a été quand
même en partie créée par là l'effet
médiatique qu'il a suscitées en partie
qui s'est lui-même cru investi d'une
étable mission je pense qu'ils se
croient toujours investi véritable
mission c'est comment dire c'est ses
supporters et se sont aussi convaincus
que ils défendent une cause donc ça ça
leur donne une force je pense que ce
parti va effectivement continuer parce
que il ya cette idée de de convictions
politiques qui dans le panorama actuel
de formation il parlait des macros et un
petit peu un petit peu confuse des gens
qui s'engagent vraiment même s'ils
savent qu'ils vont perdre et bien c'est
quand même un message qui est envoyé à
la société et donc ça peut porter mais
l'ensemble est effectivement une
manifeste enfin à énorme un énorme
désastre quand même un point de vue des
ambitions initiales d'eric zemmour mais
bruno cautrès 125000 adhérents en tout
cas c'est le chiffre officiel bon pas
forcément simple à vérifier mais faisons
leur confiance et qu'est ce que c'est
quoi c'est un club de fans de lecteurs
d'eric zemmour c'est une force politique
qui peut être utile pendant des années
le front national n'avait pas de député
à l'assemblée
malgré tout afin de continuer de peser
ou est ce que je veux dire c'est un
symptôme
du mal être et du malaise identitaire
français au fond à la fois sa
trajectoire fulgurante
à l'automne au fond seul l'électeur
d'eric zemmour ou ceux qui regardaient
ces news connaissez bien le personnage
et puis il a émergé mer assez fulgurante
en quelques semaines seulement comme on
voit là un symptôme d'un d'un malaise
français et de la même manière c'est
aussi un symptôme d'une transformation
des organisations politiques en france
on voit dans de nombreux pays européens
pas seulement en france que le parti
politique avec des strates intermédiaire
avec des militants qui l'ont issue d'un
long parcours de formation par les
organisations politiques ou par le
syndicalisme c'est plutôt une valeur qui
est à la baisse on voit émerger partout
des partis politiques qui sont portés
par une personnalité avec une très forte
personnalisation peut parler de partis
politiques personnelles on a vu que en
marche au fond il y avait quelque chose
qui était qui était qui était et qui
étaient similaires
donc voilà ma un symptôme d'un malaise
démocratique
français assez profond et c'est en ça
qu'effectivement le mouvement politique
créé par exe moore sans aucun doute ce
sera menée à muter à perpétuer mais
qu'il voit là mais qu'il est qu'il est
arrivé à capter quelque chose de ceux de
ce mal-être de ce malaise démocratique
français
quel sera le succès électoral c'est une
toute autre dimension on voit qu'au fond
si on reprend maintenant les élections
qui vont se succéder et peut-être guère
qu'aux élections européennes de 2024
qu'eric zemmour pourra tenter d'exister
avec des listes qui sont des listes
nationales où il va être sur un thème
sur lequel il a sans aucun doute des
choses à dire aux électeurs qu'ils qui
le portent aux nues mais sur les
élections locales qui s'annoncent on va
retrouver son problème pas d'ancrage pas
d'organisation politique et donc sans
doute il est déjà dans sa tête dans
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 27 je
reviens sur marine le pen donc il refuse
bien ses prises de parole ou celle de
ses lieutenants le toute alliance avec
reconquête dans quel était ce matin sur
rtl on a entendu une première partie de
ça sa réaction concernant jean luc
mélenchon quelle cible très clairement
on va l'écouter en entier c'est assez
savoureux regardez jean luc mélenchon ne
sera jamais premier ministre en revanche
si un certain nombre de français votent
pour lui il peut transformer la scène
nationale en zad et ça je ne le souhaite
pas donc la question c'est quelle
opposition à emmanuel macron c'est à
dire transformer l'assemblée nationale
en za gonzague c'est à dire avec les les
défenseurs des black blocks les
défenseurs du burkina la piscine ceux
qui veulent désormais la police ceux qui
veulent ouvrir les prisons parce que la
prison c'est pas gentil etc voilà
transformé l'assemblée on that si ça et
éventuellement c'est le risque que
que celui de jean médecin catherine
tricot à droite tout on peut on peut
dire ça alors que sa campagne
présidentielle avait été elle aurait
peut-être pas prononcer des mots comme
peu comme cela avait très clairement
c'est tout à fait différent de ce que du
message qu'elle avait voulu porter
pendant la présidentielle qui était très
social et a laissé essayer d'être la
candidate anti macro et des ailes a
cherché à séduire un électorat qui
aurait pu être tenté par faire front
contre mâcon là c'est pas ça du tout
qu'elle raconte elle revient vraiment
sur des positions très à droite avec
tous les identifiants l'islam la prison
la police l'ordre etc enfin c'est assez
assez surprenant qu'elle reprenne cette
position et donc ça je pense que ça
conforte ce qu'on a dit en première
partie c'est à dire qu'elle ne mène pas
vraiment une campagne elle va elle pense
pas pouvoir gagner elle va essayer de
faire ce qu'elle pourra faire 30 40
députés ça serait déjà quand même
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que la situation
présente voilà c'est tout je pense elle
joue pas plus que ça à mon avis mais
claire chartier c'est ce cette question
de la laïcité
stratégiquement c'est assez bien joué de
pointer ce qui est ce qui peut être un
élément de rupture ou une dissension au
sein de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale autant comme cette
fameuse union effectivement temps les
verges pour se faire battre parce que
franchement c'est vrai que fait
ressortir ce sujet là dans ce moment-là
appelé évidemment une riposte de l'autre
côté est très très facile parce qu'on
sait combien le sujet du burkini la
piscine est quand même sensible je pense
qu'elle va aussi sur ceux sur cette
question parce qu'elle n'a plus besoin
trop d'aller sur la question sociale
parce que elle a été comme très entendu
là-dessus et elle a été comprise là
dessus donc elle avait délaissé ce pan
je dirais plus droitiers classique parce
qu'en plus il était un peu effrayant
qu'il était occupé par eric zemmour là
le flanc sociale elle est vraiment
reconnue elle est reconnue comme
crédible là-dessus à tort ou à raison
donc maintenant elle peut repasser sur
ses fondamentaux ce qui effectivement
une articulation classique est habituel
dans laquelle elle est tout à fait à
l'aise et encore une fois
de l'autre côté il ya un manque de
comment dire de tactique politique pour
le moins en ce moment on parle beaucoup
de claude rich à propos de l'ukraine est
la différence entre tactiques et
stratégies à gauche c'est certain que il
ya ni tactique ni stratégie pour
l'instant on attend de voir il ya quand
même vous l'avez évoqué un peu tout à
l'heure mathieu la question de l'avenir
du rassemblement national
avec avec ou sans le clan le pen a placé
une vraie question c'est est ce qu'on
considère que j'ordonne lardé là on fait
partie d'une certaine fabien alliant
alliance voilà aussi dans ce parti voilà
mais c'est une vraie qui s'est marié
lainesse de marine le marina fais parce
que depuis sa création en 1972 le front
national est un est une affaire
familiale quand même vous le dire alors
qui est passé de père en fille dans la
difficulté enfin d'abord à doubler puis
ensuite poignardé
chacun ayant joué son rôle mais mais
c'est une vraie question parce que c'est
même une marque en politique le pen
c'est quand même une des rares femmes
politiques françaises de la personne
était politique à pouvoir faire campagne
sur son prénom parce que tout le monde
connaît son nom tout le dessin ça il ya
même plus besoin et puis il y avait pas
besoin pour elles de faire campagne
pendant cette présidentielle sur les
valeurs traditionnelles de l'extrême
droite parce qu'elle voulait les
planqués et puis parce que de toute
façon et pas besoin de surligner quelque
chose qui est explicite pour les gens
quand vous appelez le pen vous êtes issu
du front national et donc d'extrême
droite donc la succession des le pen si
jamais marine le pen venait à se retirer
du jeu ou à prendre du recul va être
très compliqué parce que c'était un clan
familial qui n'a fonctionné qu'en
éliminant tout ce qui pouvait monter et
faire de la concurrence par ailleurs
donc jordan bardella lui a été adoubé
c'est vrai qu'il est il est de la
famille par alliance
marion maréchal sera peut-être pardonner
parce qu'elle est aussi du clan et de la
famille on a vu des gens partir revenir
mais qui émerge à côté qui a émergé 1
personne personne ça a été le problème
de marine le pen dans l'entre-deux tours
c'est qu'elle se retourne et puis il y
avait pas grand monde pour former un
gouvernement éventuel pour pouvoir
répondre aux interviews on a vu que
jordan dare dare on peut le dire un peu
notre cuisine complète transparence et
est parfois compliqué je trouve ça
logique d'avoir des qualités pour
représenter marine le pen sur ce plateau
et que les choses soient claires le
front national et rassemblement national
a eu souvent ses difficultés au niveau
des élections locales ou constituer des
listes municipales certain nombre de mes
collègues j'ai fait des études on va
dire sociologique extrêmement précises
montrant que très souvent le
rassemblement national étaient obligés
d'aller piocher dans le vivier des
familles des candidats aux élections
municipales pour arriver à monter des
listes municipales donc c'est une
problématique effectivement assez assez
générale malgré la progression de marine
le pen à la présidentielle dans les
territoires ruraux par exemple ancrage
territorial et nationales du
rassemblement national s'est
considérablement
élargie au cours des deux dernières
présidentielles mais ils ont toujours
effectivement un peu ce même problème de
viviez tant au niveau de l'état majeur
du parti que souvent même au niveau
local alors c'est l'enjeu de dos rond
pour l'ostracisme quand même c'est pour
elle c est un des enjeux essentiels
d'arriver à pouvoir se structurer et là
en l'occurrence en passant à jordan
bardella d'une certaine manière elle
joue aussi cette carte des d'un
élargissement et vous parlez de stores
des partis qui étaient liées à une
personne c'était la famille le pen est
l'enjeu du rassemblement national comme
l'enjeu qui va avoir qui va être celui
de autour des manières maquereau ou
celui de jean luc mélenchon sait comment
on passe parce qu'en fait mélenchon il
va devoir passer la main sur emmanuel
macron ne sera pas candidat et donc la
question de l'avenir de ces partis néo
meneur un livre répondre à ces questions
sur ses traces sur les cinq prochaines
périodes quoi s'est passée dans dans
l'air fait du mandé partie personnelle
parmi les mouvements partis et plus du
tout et on voit bien que les partis
classiques sont complètement à la
ramasse accroche au bastingage pour ne
pas sombrer donc c'est vraiment là ce
nouveau monde sur lequel on a glosé
pendant en fait on est en train de lui
gilles en train de se fabriquer on a
beaucoup accusés emmanuel macron d'avoir
finalement contribué à la à
l'éloignement enfin à l'effacement du
clivage gauche droite par sont ni droite
ni gauche mais en fait je pense que
c'est d'abord ce qu'on voit là c'est
exactement le contraire c'est à dire
qu'au contraire c'est l'affirmation
d'une radicalité dire qu'on a quand même
effectivement il le souligne lui-même
dans son discours d'hier de radicalité
qui s'oppose donc lagos aujourd'hui
emmené par mélenchon à droite marine le
pen or la radicalité le conflit c'est de
la politique en fait et donc on est au
contraire la dans le grand retour de la
politique tel qu'il doit se concevoir
dans un débat démocratique donc de ce
point de vue là on est vraiment au coeur
et ça c'est vraiment le nouveau monde
qui est en train de se fabriquer pour
beaucoup de raisons et pas simplement
pour pour emmanuel macron confirmation
un coup d'oeil aux sondages coup d'oeil
prudent évidemment on est à un mois du
premier tour les listes sont à peine
connue
c'est harris interactive pour nos
collègues nos confrères de challenges
qui propose ce sondage où on voit la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale arrivé en tête 28% mais avec une
forte baisse par rapport à la dernière
étude -7 la majorité présidentielle à 26
le rassemblement national à 24 et puis
après voilà il ya un gap qui revient
qu'il ya ça ressemble évidemment au
score du premier tour de la
présidentielle ait l'air à neuf
reconquête à 6 etc etc ici on regarde la
projection en sièges et là encore on
être ultra prudent parce qu'elle est
compliquée à assortir cette projection
mais on arrive à plus de 300 sièges de
toutes façons majorité absolue pour la
coalition présidentielle entre 105 et
158 pour les parties de la nuque 30 à 40
8 pour lr les républicains et 52 à 80
pour le rassemblement national catherine
tricot ce qui est intéressant c'est que
quand on voit ça encore une fois on est
à un mois il va se passer il ya une
campagne qui va démarrer il ya des
dimensions locales dans chaque
circonscription qui vont jouer mais
quand même jean luc mélenchon se dit d
peut-être en train de réussir son coup
premier opposant à macron ça se profile
en tout cas c'était déjà un peu de cas
en 2017 mais de manière beaucoup plus
bas c'est à dire qu'en 2017 il était
déjà il avait revendiqué ce rôle et il
avait avec son groupe de dix-sept
insoumis qui était la première fois
qu'ils apparaissaient à l'assemblée
nationale il avait voulu être le fait de
l'arithmétique il y avait 100 députés
n'ont plus rapide on comptait pour rien
il y avait trente députés socialistes
qui n'ont pas compter non plus ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas simplement
le nombre c'est aussi la dynamique que
vous portez l'affirmation il était une
grande voix et il avait bien décidé de
d'implanter moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que ces 52 à 80 élus front national
sur un sur un élections uninominales
c'est énorme si jamais c'était confirmé
c'est énorme c'est à dire que là il ya à
la fois les aînés les les députés qui
arriverait de la france insoumise et de
la gauche mais d'une certaine manière on
est quand même un peu habitué en france
a trouvé à voir le parti communiste qui
avait une implantation est peu ou prou
la france a soumises or en place
d'un imaginaire et dans l'espace
politique la radicalité communiste mais
là c'est pas la zad qui se profile un
c'est l'émeute permanente d'extrême
droite en face honda non mais je je je
sais un peu ch a repêché un peu choqué
baisse je vais pas vous serez choisi
propre maison parce
qu'elle a fait une campagne vraiment de
proximité un présidentiel marine one et
ont regardé c'était fou en fait elle
était vraiment sur le terrain sur les
marchés est carrément fan ayant fait 52
81 députés d'extrême droite ils ont
quand même des rapports à la démocratie
qui sont des rapports un peu
conflictuelle on va dire donc ça elle
dit c'est mélenchon ça va être la zad
moi ce que je me dis c'est que autant
d'électeurs de députés d'extrême droite
à l'assemblée nationale c'est quand même
une contestation possible dans
l'hémicycle des principes républicains
et démocratiques et ses paysages rêvés
d'emmanuel macron faut le dire c'est
exactement comme ça qu'il imaginait ce
nouveau monde politique avec deux
radicalités qui selon lui n'auront
jamais de majorité sociologique en
france donc il se dit on est tranquille
mois j'occupe le centre il y aura jamais
50% deal se distille un plus une voix
qui voteront pour une radicalité
d'extrême gauche de gauche et jamais non
plus pour l'exemple droite donc c'est
l'exploit de cendres qui occupera leur
alors là la question puis après on va
passer au nouveau gouvernement quand
même changement de mode de scrutin
proportionnel avec ces chiffres là au
premier tour 28 26 24 c'est pas la même
c'est
clair qu'en 2017
l'assemblée a été l'assemblée nationale
élu a obtenu les coefficients de
distorsion de la représentation nouveau
calcul des indicateurs statistiques qui
calcule la distorsion des voix au siège
la plus d'efforts mais toute la 5ème
république en particulier rassemblement
national et la france est soumise mais
surtout le rassemblement national
qui n'auront obtient pas du tout à
proportion de ce qu'il a fait je parle
pas de la présidentielle les mêmes aux
législatives au nombre de députés le
décalage est considérable pour la france
insoumise et également donc c'est vrai
qu'un souci de la proportionnalité de
l'assemblée élue emmanuel macron a
indiqué qu'il allait s'en occuper donc
ça sera pas pour eux là ce sera pour les
élections de l'initiative de 2027 mais
c'est vrai qu'à la proportionnelle ça
donnerait une assemblée totalement
différente avec sans aucun doute des
conséquences extrêmement importante sur
la coalition ça poserait directement la
question d'une coalition par exemple
majorité présidentielle les républicains
se serait on serait en train de parler
de ça effectivement alors on va parler
de l'autre fait politique de cette
journée le dernier conseil des ministres
du gouvernement
castex après deux faux départs c'est la
bonne le président de la république
d'ailleurs a rendu un hommage appuyé à
jean castex est ce que gabriel attal a
raconté ce matin il a indiqué qu' il ya
près de deux ans jean castex a accepté
de diriger un gouvernement de combat oui
il ya eu des combats depuis deux ans
avec des crises évidemment la crise
sanitaire la guerre en ukraine aussi
évidemment beaucoup d'autres beaucoup
d'autres enjeux il a remercié à nouveau
jean castex d'avoir accepté cette
mission il a dis avec solennité et
affection qu'il avait été très fier
d'être autour de cette table avec jean
castex et avec son gouvernement ces deux
dernières années mathieu on peut dire
que cet hommage n'était pas feinte il ya
plein de bonnes raisons pour faire pour
en aucun cas ce texte aura été un
premier ministre idéal idéal pourquoi
vahid elle se veut d'abord dire loyal
rendez vous compte qu'en deux ans on n'a
pas eu le début de commencement d'une
fuite d'un tiraillement entre les deux
têtes de l'exécutif m notable il y a
toujours pour emmanuel macron c'est ça
veut dire travailleur et sur ce point
jean castex a montré ses montres et
quand même d'une abnégation sans faille
faisant tout ce que lui demandait le
président en assumant les virages et les
revirements les textes de loi et les
confinements idéal ça veut aussi dire
modeste et modeste jean castex a été
dans la courbe de ces sondages qu'elle
épouse et de façon très scrupuleuse
celle du président il l'a été aussi dans
ses ambitions il rêvait pas d'être
calife à la place du calife jean castex
il a laissé le chef d'état prendre le
chef de l'état prendre la lumière quand
il le souhaitait lui se chargeant du
sale boulot il a été à commandant il a
accepté sans broncher cette
hyperprésidence avec un emmanuel macron
qui décide de tout tout seul et et lui
se satisfaisant jean castex du rôle de
collaborateur idéal enfin toujours pas
ce que ça veut dire complémentaires ils
étaient capables une forme
d'horizontalité pour compenser la
verticalité du président capable face à
ce président des villes d'être un
premier ministre deschamps capable
d'apparaître proche des gens et les
pieds dans la glaise ou cherchant ses
lunettes dans ses poches alors qu'on dit
emmanuel macron autun lointain
voir voire cassant son seul acte de
résistance au fond ça aura été de
refuser d'aller jusqu'aux législatives
de rester à matignon jusqu'aux
législatives il a dit non il n'en était
pas question et un moment faut quand
même pas pousser jean castex plus loin
que cris de le souhaiterez mais est ce
que madame lacroix a forcément besoin
d'un profil similaire pour ce second
quinquennat mais tout dépend en fait
lequel quelques couleurs et entend
donner à ce début de son quinquennat et
quelle méthode il entend employer parce
que jean castex étaient idéales pour
emmanuel macron mais il avait aussi des
défauts ou les ou des inconvénients
c'est que c'est pas un premier ministe
politique au sens partisan du terme au
sens on peut l'être un chef de la
majorité ou un chef de meute c'était à
la fois son avantage mais aussi sa
limite parce que sa parole
l'impressionné guère les les poids
lourds de la macro ni ni les élus ni
même les électeurs d'une certaine façon
il était la main du président et jean
castex avait la réputation d'être un
négociateur hors pair mais il n'a pas
non plus su renouer particulièrement le
fils que ce soit avec les élus locaux on
l'a bien vu lors des élections de à la
tête de l'association des maires de
france ou avec les partenaires sociaux
il ya quand même quelque chose qui
interroge on a deux poids lourds du
gouvernement vous prenez jean michel
blanquer ou eric dupond moretti qui ne
parle plus alors syndicat maison depuis
deux ans c'est quand même pour un chef
de gouvernement qui était censé renouer
le fil du dialogue ça pose question mais
enfin jean castex était un bon techno un
bon connaisseur donc voilà on voit un
peu le les choix doivent avoir le même
wagon s'il veut vraiment changer de
méthode d'abord il va falloir que lui il
fasse un grand travail sur lui-même
qu'il apprenne le fica fixer un cap à
déléguer à des grands centres et la
décision et peut-être du coup a confié
le bébé un premier ministre politique
s'il veut continuer de décider de tout à
toute heure il faudra un nouveau
collaborateur au risque de tuer une
bonne fois pour toutes le job de du
locataire de matignon a effectivement
catherine tricot là c'est la méthode
macron qui qui est à l'épreuve ou qui
sera à l'épreuve oui dans le coin dans
le comté ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure
c'est dire que ça va être tendu au sein
de la macro ni signac on voit déjà que
les négociations sont difficiles pour
les élections législatives c'est à dire
qu'on fait ce profil il yal équilibre de
la politique qui va être mené est-ce
qu'elle va être écologique est ce qu'il
va y avoir la retraite à 65 ans contre
les syndicats ce qu'ils vont passer en
force à quel rythme etc et puis il ya
l'avenir de ce mouvement qui est de
droite et de gauche et qui essaie de
repousser aux extrêmes et il ya beaucoup
de monde qui pense pouvoir être
la relève possible et en ce sens moi
j'ai l'impression qu'un premier ministre
qui serait que un techno aurait du mal
est-ce qu'il va falloir quelqu'un pour
tenir un peu les chevaux
calmes mais déjà pour mener cette
campagne et cela tous niveaux il ya
cette première échéance dans quatre
semaines mais plus long terme c'est
falloir quand même mettre de l'ordre
dans cette maison pour tenir un
quinquennat
avec un appui politique des mâts pour
emmanuel mac ou qui n'est pas s'y
installer que ça il n'a pas fait de
campagne quand même à l'élection
présidentielle
m quelle semaine non mais fait quatre
semaines de campagne on peut pas dire
qu'il a eu un mandat qui relève d'un
débat politique profond dans la société
donc il va falloir qu'ils fassent son
mandat et qu'il calme les ambitieux
pense qu'après un premier ministre
charpenté serait nécessaire le présent
un public qui aurait oedt au
conditionnel essuyé plusieurs refus de
personnalités féminines puisque il
chercherait à vue une première miss ça
vous a surpris oui ça m'a surpris ce
parce que c'est vrai que c'est quand
même pas banal enfin moi en tout cas a
dit non ça ne se refuse pas ces deux les
interlocuteurs me disait quand même en
évoquant l'une des trois personnalités
féminines en question qui dirige un
groupe qui mobilise et quand même entre
ce groupe là est le premier ministre
c'est à ça il n'y a pas photo donc
bassila photo visiblement donc les
règles du jeu ont changé c'est ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure et
effectivement là c'est encore un exemple
du nouveau monde et puis de finalement
de cette distance prise par mais même
par l'opinion publique au sens large pas
simplement par les personnalités dont on
parle par rapport aux règles classiques
politique pour revenir un instant sur le
premier mini je pense que ça tient aussi
à ou statut de la vouloir lui donner
emmanuel macron parce que en fait si le
premier ministre a est considérée est
investie comme tel par emmanuel macron
comme un chef de la majorité ce qu'il
est censé être constitutionnellement et
bien là il aura ce rôle-là deux parce
qu'un chef de la majorité au premier
ministre c'est celui qui va parler ou
députés qui met du lien qui fait de la
pédagogie et qui donc aussi tiens tout
cet ensemble et qui est effectivement
relativement disparates donc ça va pas
être très facile cette confédération de
majorité présidentielle mais tout dépend
de la volonté l'asnl emmanuel macron
indépendamment du nom c est ce qui va
vouloir véritablement investir son
premier ministre de cette mission la
saint nicolas sarkozy ne l'avait pas
fait vous avez évoqué de mon
collaborateur c'est ce que ça voulait
dire donc entre collaborateurs et chef
de la majorité termes que nicolas
sarkozy on peut les interviews pour
qualifier donc cibler ses sept cette
attitude là les matelas qu'on l'ait pas
nouvelle puisqu'elle a été effectivement
initié par nicolas sarkozy il est les
deux s'entendent bien d'ailleurs mais
donc on va voir quel est le choix des
manuels macron sur exactement le rôle
qui va lui faire jouer et l'avenir de
jean castex haillan termine là dessus
bruno cautrès moi je mets un pari qui va
devenir personnalité politique préférée
des français parce qu'il va plus faire
grand chose parce que finalement on va
se souvenir qu'il était là où soutien
dans une période difficile oui je n'ai
aucun doute sur la même chose que vous
effectivement il deviendra une des
personnalités politiques préférées des
français d'abord parce que pour toutes
les raisons qui ont été rappelés tout à
l'heure son profil relativement modeste
il n'a pas incarné l'avidité d'exercer
le pouvoir coûte que coûte
effectivement il restera très fortement
associé dans la mémoire des français à
la gestion du coc vide fondamentalement
et aussi à l'inflexion de la gestion du
coc vide parce que tout début on se
rappelait plus mais c'était pas simple
la gestion du du cabinet lui arrive donc
je pense qu'il va rester très associé
pour les français à la gestion du coc
vide le personnage il est arrivé à créer
un personnage et ça c'est important pour
conserver la mémoire des français
incarner quelque chose son accent sa
particularité effectivement ça va pas
être simple en fait de lui succéder
parce qu'il faut trouver quelqu'un qui
non seulement réunit toutes les qualités
dont on a parlé mais aussi n'oublions
pas qu'emmanuel macron ne pouvant pas
être candidat à un troisième mandat au
bout d'un an beaucoup de gens se
poseront la question de savoir si jamais
il ya un très bon premier ministre
quelqu'un qui incarne bien un peu
charismatique est-ce que c'est pas lui
ou elle le successeur à suivre d'autres
débats à venir sur son plateau ça promet
d'être passionnant merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé voilà ce premier
débat de sens public